long before robert pattinson signed on
the dotted line two stars Bruce Wayne in
the Batman the internet lit up like a
Christmas tree with hot takes on the
news now director Matt Reeves has broken
his silence on the baton sin hullabaloo
kind of on June 3rd Reeves addressed
Pattinson 'he's casting in the batman in
a very 2019 way he posted a [ __ ] of
Pattinson in 2017 s criminally
underrated good time and then added
three bat emojis for a caption while
Warner Brothers hasn't released an
official statement about Pattinson
involvement as of the making of this
video
Reeves is simple tweet basically seals
the deal the chip and caption
combination gets the message across
perfectly Pattinson is the new Bruce
Wayne and Reeves clearly wants fans to
be aware of Pattinson 'he's most
critically acclaimed role to date and
not overtly praising Pattinson the
filmmaker didn't stoke the fires burning
on the side of social media that wants
to vilify Pattinson and slam him as a
terrible choice to succeed Ben Affleck
is Batman on the basis that he starred
in The Twilight movies the better part
of a decade ago
Reeves did just enough to let his
thoughts be heard without making the
situation even more divisive than it
already is
when Pattinson's name first sprang up in
connection with the Batman thousands of
people hopped on Twitter to shout into
the social media sphere about what they
thought of the English actor portraying
Bruce Wayne many shared that they
absolutely hate the idea while some were
conflicted by the whole notion like film
critic Mike McGranahan who tweeted I
honestly don't know how to feel about
Robert Pattinson his Batman on one hand
I hate the idea because I can't even
remotely picture him as The Dark Knight
on the other hand I absolutely love the
idea for the exact same reason others
held nothing back in denouncing
Pattinson as a poor pick for Batman one
user wrote I've never been so
disappointed in a Batman casting Robert
Pattinson is a horrible choice to play
the character someone else directly
called out Reeves and criticized him for
casting Pattinson as the new Dark Knight
writing I've loved Batman films since
being a child and you've completely
ruined it for me and hundreds of
thousands of others by casting Robert
Pattinson as Batman you should check the
comment sections on pages which have
shared this news bad move
while those individuals were huffing and
puffing over the Pattinson news others
were firing shots at the naysay
and defending Warner Brothers and Reeves
his decision to cast Pattinson his
batman an argument many repeated in
their pro patents and tweets involved
Heath Ledger's casting as the Joker
when Ledger was confirmed for the Joker
plenty didn't like the thought of the
actor entering the DC movie world to
play the infamous villain for the sole
reason that he had made a name for
himself with light-hearted movies like
10 Things I Hate About You as we all
know Ledger proved everyone wrong and
his take on the Joker is now a favorite
amongst fans
yes many believe the same thing could
end up happening with Pattinson as
performances Batman like artist Jen
Bartels said Robert Pattinson hasn't
been Edward Cullen since 2012 Heath
Ledger was known for playing teenage
heart throbs and movies like 10 Things I
Hate About You and a Knight's Tale
before he went on to play what is widely
considered the most terrifying version
of the Joker grow up some may still be
unsure of Pattinson z' ability to knock
the Batarang out of the park when he
dons the cape and cowl in the batman but
there are several reasons why he's
actually a flawless fit for the role
more so than any of the dozen or so
other actors once rumored to be in
consideration how would you like it if I
made you cry would you like that
he's got the acting chops the broody
nature required to play the tortured
billionaire orphan and as William Dafoe
astutely pointed out the strong chin
needed to embody Bruce Wayne the Batman
is scheduled to fly into theaters on
June 25th 2021 then the world can decide
whether baton sin is better or worse
than batfleck
that's fear check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the DC EU are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]